have you seen more churches becoming
woke for an extreme example as I saw one
church with a transgender Jesus
why would the act of sacrifice Jesus
which is he's basically sacrificing
himself he agrees to do this why does
that save people okay so then what made
you settle on Christianity over anything
else I kind of got to the point where I
realized that Christianity makes the
most sense of all of reality
this episode is brought to you by
nordvpn a VPN like nordvpn is a good
idea because the internet is super
sketch at the moment I suppose it's
always been super sketch nordvpn doesn't
slow down my internet and then I don't
have to think about or worry about what
website I'm going to or where I'm
ordering from where I'm ordering what
from what I'm researching Etc I think
it's just a smart thing for people to
have if they're online you can go to
nordvpn.com
tmpp or use promo code tmpp for 61 off
their Premium plan plus their free
anti-malware feature go to Nord vpn.com
tmpp or use that code for 61 off and you
get their 30-day money-back guarantee so
protect yourself online I use nordvpn
[Music]
John McRae welcome to my podcast
yo thanks for having me appreciate it
okay so this has been a long time coming
we spoke first
um what was it it was okay you would
remember
we were on a podcast together was it
Justin brierley
Justin Briley yeah brierley okay yeah
and that's yeah and I've wanted to talk
to you kind of since then
um mostly because so I'm I'm fairly new
uh
about I guess within Christianity and my
beliefs and so
I've been interviewing a couple people
some one person Jonathan peggio who he
did he was Christian Orthodox which
isn't I think the direction I'm going in
but um that was very interesting but
I've been wanting to talk to you for a
while so I think before we get started
can you give a brief background about
what did you you do and who you are
yeah no
um my name is John McRae and I run the
YouTube channel called what do you mean
um there's not too much that's not
interested about me I don't think but um
basically I just like that yeah I like
to just like look at culture and look at
Christianity and try to communicate the
gospel to culture in a way that they can
understand and try to kind of make it
clear and concise you know so that's
really kind of my focus I mean I've
studied a lot of you know like
apologetics and philosophy and I'm sure
we'll get into some of that a little bit
later but yeah so that's about it
so what made you decide to go down that
path I mean becoming a becoming a large
YouTuber
by teaching people about Christianity
isn't exactly the way to become a large
YouTuber right yeah no that's a good
question so
um it kind of happened accidentally and
I'm not sure how far back we want to go
but
um long story short
um I lost my hearing randomly um in like
my mid-20s so I randomly just kind of
lost my hearing went deaf um in both the
years I had 10 percent here under left
in this year and 15 Karen left in this
year and the doctors didn't know what
happened what caused it what not and so
my hearing started going down and I used
to play music so I figured it was from
like playing music too loud and stuff
but then when I got to the doctor
they're like no it's um it's too
significant to be music you know they're
like it's something else like and they
don't know what caused it there's a lot
they still don't know about
um here in Ross and so I had to get a
cochlear implant and um are you familiar
with at all I know yeah you can explain
though for people who aren't familiar
yeah no problem so the cochlear implant
has a internal and external component
and it's a hearing device and what they
do is there's um underneath my skull
they surgically implanted a chip that's
attached to these electrodes and they
pump those into
um through your skull through your ear
canal so that way it functions like the
hair follicles and so it's digital and
then there's an external component that
attaches with a magnet so once I turned
on my processor and attach it then it
turns on and um what really sucks about
it though is because after you get the
surgery you can't hear for a long time
because your body has to relearn how to
hear all over again and it's a hard
process so when I first got mine turned
on it sounded like you know those old
school dallop modems you know all those
kind of weird ticks and beeps and stuff
yeah something like those yeah and it
was it was like that for over a year it
was about a year in some when I started
being able to hear again and but I had
to relearn it and it was a slow long
process so it was during that time
though that I started getting online and
started just like debate and atheists
and stuff and some of these um these um
Facebook groups on Facebook and so I was
doing that for a while and there was a
guy that was always kind of watching me
or I mean I was talking with me and
watching in these debates and he's like
you should start a YouTube channel and
he was a guy that lived in Australia and
I was like uh I didn't really watch a
lot of YouTube and I was like I don't
really know what that would be I never
thought about it before and he's like
look I want to send you a camera and all
this stuff you need to get started he's
like just do it and give it a shot and
so I did and then yeah and we ended up
here a couple years later so
wow was this another Christian
yeah yeah
okay that's cool so have you been a
Christian your entire life were you
brought up in a Christian family
no I wasn't no so we weren't like we
never went to church on eventually we
never even talked about God and like my
whole time kind of grown up
um I was first introducing the debate
when I was 15.
um and so I went to a church with my
aunt
um but it was weird because I was
introduced to this kind of Christianity
though like now I just you know just
don't agree with it I just don't believe
any of it but it was really kind of
cultish like it was really legalistic
and so like it kind of left like a weird
kind of bad taste in my mouth afterwards
and so after that I was kind of just
kind of agnostic like sometimes
believing in God sometimes not believing
in God and then eventually I um
um sort of come I took a philosophy
religion class in college and in
philosophy of religion we went through
the arguments for God's existence
um and that sort of thing and then
that's when I started becoming convinced
that God existed um one particular
argument the colon Cosmic Hospital
argument I just was persuaded by and
then that's what kind of started me
believing in God and then I started
visiting a bunch of different churches
and throughout visiting these different
churches I to start asking people
questions about why they believe that
their belief is true and why they
believe though the beliefs were false
and I keep getting all these kind of
similar answers no matter what type of
church I went to and I mean I went to
like the Church of Scientology I wanted
to like every kind of church you can
think of
yeah and kept in the same kind of
answers you know like their life got
better or
um you know there's a bunch of kind of
things that happened in their life that
was like show them that this church was
true so it was a lot of stuff like that
and then eventually I came across the
evidence for the Resurrection online
instead of studying that and was
convinced by the the argument for the
resurrection
interesting okay so you even went the
Scientology route and you said you had
similar answers kind of across the board
about why they believed whatever they
were believing was right so what was
what did that answer look like
yeah so it was mostly just those
um a bunch of people say that you know
life has changed since I started joining
this church we're following god
um and then they would say like there
was all these kind of usually like some
sort of set of like coincidences or
something things that would happen that
they couldn't explain else was include
yeah things like that that was the
reason why their church was true and
they knew that God existed wow and is
this this is for everyone including like
Scientology this is just across the
board yeah yeah across the board yeah
that's why I was so interesting to me
too because it's like you you when you
start doing that because you don't I
guess like I guess at least I don't
think like I wouldn't expect that you
know and so when I started talking to
all these people it was really strange
to me because I said man there's
something that's kind of embedded in
human psychology or or I mean who knows
the explanation for it perhaps maybe
um God is using you know I mean God is
giving these people signs and stuff but
the problem with it is that like for my
in my mind it was that all of these
different religions couldn't be true
because they were all mutually exclusive
you know and so that was like the big
problem in my mind and so that's why I
was kind of like my first kind of
introduction into like looking at
religion and stuff way more in depth and
that's when I started getting online
while and studying these different
religions and stuff and what they
believe and so on
okay so then what made you settle on
Christianity over anything else yeah
yeah this is a long process too because
um it's a lot of thinking and stuff even
when I started doing the debates and
stuff part of it was me trying to figure
out what I believed and stuff and
looking up at evidence and then testing
it with you know my arguments with
people who disagreed and stuff like that
um but it was a long process really I
think it was like ultimately the
historicity of the Resurrection
um I became convinced I mean I think
that I mean also only agree that Jesus
is a real person who existed in history
you know and when you follow these sort
of
um objective kind of standards and
methods that they use in order to come
to
um uh historical facts I think that when
you do that you come across a lot of
facts that I think is only explained by
the fact that Jesus actually did raise
from the dead and so for me that was
like
um the thing where I spent a lot of time
thinking about it too like trying to run
it around in my head trying to like
argue it with myself and with other
people and so on and I just slowly
became more convinced of it and I kind
of got to the point where I realized
that Christianity makes the most sense
of all of reality so it's not just like
you know this external reality as well
like say the beginning of the universe
you know when you look at that or when
you look at like why is there something
rather than nothing like Consciousness
you know when you look at that um but
also with your internal world as well so
with your internal world too you're like
why are humans this way why do we have
this impulse where we have this like
near Universal agreement that you
shouldn't do things that are wrong like
still kill or Rob and lie and all these
things but we still do those things you
know and so like it made sense to me of
both the objective world and also my
subjective world as well
aren't there other religions that kind
of abide by the same rules like people
that people are bad or at least killing
stealing murder all that is bad that you
shouldn't do it but we still do it does
not line up with a number of other
religions
yeah but I don't understand the
explanation for why that's the case and
these other information right so yeah
because I think in Christianity if you
have the view of like the sin nature and
power off like
um you know subject to the to being
slaves to the sin nature then it makes a
lot more sense in my opinion and then
Christianity is the only religion that
actually solves this problem as well you
know what I mean and so it's like you
have this problem of life is perfectly
holy God and then you have and then so
it's like how could we live in the
presence of a perfectly holy God
um or perfectly moral God how do we live
in his presence unless we two are
perfect you know and so I think that
Christianity actually takes the idea of
sin a lot more seriously because it's
like God Is So holy and he's so morally
perfect and righteous that in order to
be in his presence we would also need to
be holy and righteous and so it's like
how do we solve that problem like what
is the problem and what is the solution
and that's what it really boils down to
in my mind and it's like Christianity
solves it because
um only in Christianity do you have God
who is also perfect of course God okay
coming into our world putting on human
flesh and coming into our world and
living that perfect life that we
couldn't live so that way when uh and
then given us that life is you know as a
sacrifice for us and so when he's given
us his life I mean given us his life
um in our place then we can actually
stand before God with his imputed
righteousness is what it's called the
doctrine of computer righteousness but
we have that righteousness now so that
way we can be in heaven if that makes
sense
yeah it does
this is so this is where I've had a
difficult time understanding why would
the act of sacrifice like so Jesus is
which is he's basically sacrificing
himself he agrees to do this why does
that save people
yeah um
and so maybe I probably didn't
articulate this as well but really it's
because we have to so when you look at
the Bible as a whole you can start up
the Old Testament what you have is like
humans are separated from God they're
separating themselves from God because
they're trying to go their own way and
so like I said nature of believes that
we can get all of our happiness we like
we don't leave God we can get all of
these things depart from God right and
so we separate ourselves from God
through sin
um but if you look at the Old Testament
too there was always a sacrifice of a
perfect
um animal it was like they've got these
unpluggish animals and stuff in the Old
Testament and then they would be used as
a mediator between God because of the
pureness of the animal and it was really
become symbolic to at that time is royal
oh yeah okay okay okay yeah kinda so
okay okay I get that as a mediation
between okay I can kind of understand
that I've just had a hard time like uh
these things resonate with me on a level
that I can't exactly describe but I've
had a hard time understanding why is it
sacrifice why is that that's what saves
you
yeah
it's complicated
it is no it is I think it's because you
you would need like kind of like going
back to that example what I said about
like being in uh a perfect God's
presence you need Perfection of that
sort right and so if you aren't perfect
the way you become rightly related to
God is through the
um a sacrifice of someone that is
perfect and so like Jesus is the
Fulfillment of
um you know the New Testament so Jesus
becomes that unblemished lamb that
perfect sacrifice for us because his
life is perfect and so it's his impute
of righteousness that we get from
believing and so if we believe we get
that and treated righteousness on our
behalf so that way God sees because of
God's perfect mercy and Justice as well
too right um
um yeah I'm jumping over topics I'm
sorry but
um okay good so his perfect
um so god is perfect in Justice right
and so if a judge is perfectly just he
has to punish every single run I'm doing
right and it's also the thing that's
separated us between God right
um but God is also perfectly most
possible and so because it's perfectly
merciful he made a way for us to be
rightly related to him and that was
through the sacrifice of Jesus that
makes sense
yeah so Jesus Took on the punishment in
that aspect
cool
okay I'm glad we delved into that a
little bit I think that's what's stuck
like when I first so last summer I had
the same kind of experience that you
said you saw everywhere which was a
whole bunch of really strange things
happened
they like they lined up and then when I
started believing my life changed so it
was like too many weird things that I
couldn't explain happened until God was
the most logical explanation and then
once I started believing my life changed
for the better so that sounds like what
people experience regardless of whatever
religion they're looking at
um but I did I did land on Christianity
and one of the things that kind of
Had Me Like stuck a little bit and I
started going to this church I found I
finally found a church I wanted to talk
to you about this too about the
importance of finding a church because
um my husband so he's been Christian for
his entire life and in the last year we
were in Tennessee and things and he kept
pushing me to go to church and I'd go to
church and I'd be like I wasn't it
wasn't resonating the pastor I felt was
posturing like it felt like I was
listening to a cult like it's just I had
a whole bunch of warning things go off
in my head and I'm like I'm not that
interested in
not to like talk negatively about
churches but I wasn't that interested in
going to like a gymnasium and listening
to somebody posture under fluorescent
lights for my Sunday I was like it's not
sorry I can't even fake me liking this
for you it's like I can't do it I'm
pretty disagreeable and and we looked
around and then we found this pastor in
like uh just north of Miami and he's
complete like he's good he's great so
we're going there and that's amazing and
I don't get any like weird culty Vibes
um yeah what's what's been your
experience with churches
man I I'm so interested because because
I never grew up in a church going home
or anything like that church yeah has
always been weird to me in some ways
yeah me too yeah it's the strangest
thing because it's like man like the
facade it feels like that a lot of
people put on it's like you know you
have like all the dead Flanders it's
like Christians yeah and stuff like that
it's awkward you know what I mean and so
it's like that those churches kind of
turn me off and so we found this church
too that was uh where people seem to be
normal like I just want to meet normal
people and talk normal conversations you
know what I mean and so um and then
learn like a normal person you know and
so like I think like
um I think especially for us like as
Millennials I think like we want like
just authenticity like people that are
just authentic and offensive Community
you know but I agree I mean it's been
tough for me too like just to kind of
not only just feel like I belong you
know what I mean but also be able to
feel like um
um I'm gonna learn something too and I'm
not just here yeah literally like
anecdotal like you know just stories or
something that's like mostly story like
I like to learn when I go to church too
which I don't know how most people are
but anyways yeah so I I always had a
kind of an uncomfortable relationship
with church as well so
okay that's good I think one of the
reason I talked to my dad about it too
because he talks about like
he talks about the importance of
community and everything and my mom
um she's Catholic at the moment she's
been going to church and
um
I was like I can't do it and he was like
Yeah The reason we never went to church
like we we weren't he we were always
taught the psychological significance of
the Bible not the Bible being real like
that's what that's what I was taught
um but he was like part of the reason we
didn't go to church was because they're
just like it was fake it felt fake felt
like people posturing it felt fake and I
couldn't stand it
yeah yeah and it like it's yeah I I
think I would have probably like if I'd
gone to or been introduced to a
community of people maybe I was pretty
skeptical so maybe it wouldn't have
worked but as a kid instead of kind of
the
the churches that just feel a little
yeah like Ned flansery and
flanders-ish ish but like okay okay so
that's normal that's good
and maybe from not being in it yeah from
not being in it maybe less tolerance for
that just get yeah okay I agree I agree
yeah I was gonna ask too like what was
it like I was kind of been curious like
so if your dad kind of has more of that
psychological perspective have you seen
my video my videos on your dad any of
them I know I saw one pop up on YouTube
I haven't watched it though okay okay no
worries okay because I kind of analyzed
kind of his perspective but if you think
like your perspective differs from his
in that sense
um because you have more of like an
objective kind of view of Christianity
right like this actually happened is
that right that's what I thought and
what do you think causes that cause that
difference just kind of curious
um
so I think Dad goes back and forth
I think the longer he's talking about it
the more he's moving towards the
objective View
um I think
understanding as much about psychology
as he does
there are I mean
there's psychological significance to
the Bible
and I believe it's objective
right so like there's psychological
significance like every aspect of the
Bible in multiple ways Plus
plus it's objective and so I think he
probably got wrapped up in
in the cycle psychological significance
and and honestly if you're if you have
more of a scientific background
um
we were told for a very long time that
like science if you believed in science
then you couldn't believe in the Bible
which I think is ridiculous like I don't
think that that was necessary at all
like those two things didn't have to be
Polar Opposites
um yeah so I think he got wrapped up in
that but I also think that he's writing
he's writing a book at the moment called
we who wrestle with god
um yeah it's going to be intense
um and he thinks he can disprove atheism
so I would I would say he's whatever
direction that that's in he's going in
so yeah I'm looking forward to it
well because it seems like he has a uh I
think he's done a talk and I don't watch
it on the problem of perception which is
kind of like a philosophical problem of
how do you get from the subjective to
the objective and so when I've heard a
lot of his stuff it seems like that's
where kind of the barrier is it's like
okay we have the psychological World The
Narrative world I think he calls it a
lot of times too but then how do you go
from that to like what's objective
what's external of your Consciousness
and your conscious perception and so I
think um that's what seems like that
holds them backward that's not probably
not necessarily a barrier for you in
that sense
I think it wasn't a barrier for me
um because so many strange things have
happened to me like even as a kid I was
so I was so sick I was suffering so much
I can remember like when I was when I
had my hip and Ankle replaced and I was
in like I was in so much pain it was
unbelievable for an entire year like
broken bones but like not able to be
fixed and I remember thinking
at that point that like
something had to be real like I didn't
know if God was real but that amount of
pain and suffering like something evil
had to be real
um and and then things were just have
been super weird with my life like being
that ill like unbelievably stupidly like
job level ill I remember reading job and
being like I've got a lot of those
things going on like my family hasn't
died but like a lot of those things were
going on and then having like fixing it
with a diet that like nobody believed
right like what is that about and then
having my mom get really sick and then
my dad get really sick and then my dad
get famous for like it's just things
have been so absurd that it's like yeah
well that stuff could have happened
it seems logical life's pretty weird
yeah yeah that is because you you have
had a different life like you know I was
thinking even like I was thinking what
it'd be like for you to do to like
you're living your life and then all of
a sudden your dad like explodes in a
social Consciousness like out nowhere
see that will throw everything off as
well too it's like all the stuff you
went through as a kid then the
autoimmune aspects that you had to and
then trying to do diet that nobody else
is
um you know people think you're probably
like they're like what is that right
like yeah that would be so it makes
sense to me why like you kind of like
yeah start processing things a different
way
yeah the other thing I do think
contributed to this and I've had some
like negative feedback about this but I
did do
and this was well mostly because I was
interested in them but I did do
psychedelics quite a bit I haven't done
it in a while but I did do them quite a
bit and I think that
really I'm not saying that's the way to
do it because people are like that's not
how you have to do it I'm like yes I
agree but I think for me for me it like
put me in a state where I was seeing
things that aren't there
and uh and that I don't for whatever
reason I was like well
those experiences probably led me to
believe God was a possibility because
you can't see him exactly right okay
kind of see things that happen kind of
but like you have to believe there isn't
like that's I think one of the things I
didn't understand until more recently
was there isn't like
at least this is and I still believe
this there isn't some definitive proof
that everyone is going to believe that
like oh well here's the proof of God
um yeah although I think Dad maybe in
his new book is trying to do something
like that but regardless like there's
you have to suspend judgment a little
bit right you have to believe
um
I do think psyched dogs help me do that
because they showed me things I couldn't
see
my thinking about it is like it's almost
like everything else I think all of us
need to get out of Our Own Way in some
way but it's like for example when
people go to prison right like and then
they find God in prison which happens to
a lot of people yeah before being
homeless so these sorts of things like
God can use these um different kind of
situations in order to point us to our
um pulling us to himself and so I think
like
um it's not a priest of day I don't I
wouldn't say like people need to go try
psychedelics to find God right because I
think that's just the means in which God
used
um because God uses us through the
things like that we do and the things we
do wrong and like all of these different
ways like everything that we do God can
still use any of these things in order
to draw us to himself so I think in that
time
um you know God just use that that
moment I guess in that aspect
um you know at least you were open to it
I guess from that you know and then God
was walking on the door I mean so in
some ways so my thinking on it is like I
mean I think that like the Bible tells
us to be so reminded so um you know so
whatever that entails but I don't I
wouldn't say that you should do
psychedelics you know in that aspect but
um I think that in this aspect it's like
it was
um God used it for good you know he
turns all things around for good for
those that love himself this episode is
brought to you by better fed beef the
holidays are here let's be honest pretty
much everyone prefers beef to ham or
turkey so why not treat yourself to some
of the tastiest and most tender beef out
there by going to betterfedbeef.com and
using Code MP for a whopping 25 off I
don't know how they give you guys that
and also make money this is the beef I
eat every day and I can eat any beef I
want which is a pretty sweet deal these
are the guys I choose to eat so that's
saying something they're super tender
and importantly I do care about this
stuff they care for their animals it's a
family-run business and the meat is
super good they have a killer deal too
25 off with code MP if you've never
tried Anya beef then you should taste
the difference the stuff is good it's
very tender comes from amazing Family
Farm arms that treat their cows right
just go to betterfedbeef.com and use
code MP for 25 off your order it's a
good deal check them out it's what I eat
I like them okay that's kind of the
conclusion I've come to
like there were there were a couple of
things it was like that that was like a
little push and then some really bad
like really dark desperate moments you
know uh yeah at the like rock bottom
is incredibly when I converted
yeah yeah like I because I remember
hearing just three I don't I don't think
so it's crazy because I said so when I
talked earlier about like everybody
having these kind of coincidences and
stuff like that I would put that in that
same category I'd say like I don't know
the cause like so the cost could be gone
right and I'd say like it could be other
things but regardless God still used
that situation to draw into himself and
so in that aspect I mean that's like I'm
not against experiences or anything like
that you know I guess uh for me I just
think that we need to try to tether them
and balance them out with objective
reality you know so that way we know
like what's true because you figure say
you have an experience about uh Muhammad
or something like this right you convert
to Islam and you become a terrorist
right and so like that wouldn't be good
you know what I mean so it's like you
want to try to like what is actually
true you know what I mean and if it's
like whatever's actually true we want to
have our beliefs correspond with reality
and you know try not to go up the deep
end
yeah I like that
I like that I've probably had so many
strange things happen to me too that
I like I don't believe you know a bunch
of the things I believed in kind of
crumbled over the last probably since
2016 like media you know any anything I
read in the media I don't know of
anything online I read is true and then
anything the government says I have no
idea of anything they say is true true
and I don't know how deep that goes and
then it's like even censoring on social
media platforms it's like oh that sounds
like paranoia and then Elon Musk buys
Twitter and is like nah you weren't
being paranoid enough and it's just like
I think I've probably I've probably uh
switched over to trying to understand
things intuitively which is something I
would have just like murdered myself
over if I'd heard myself say that as
like a 17 year old it's like oh you're
going on intuition okay there but I
think I've probably switched over to
like no I know on some level that feels
right and that's probably been
strengthened since converting I think
that's easy easier like I never
understood before if I did things you
know you know if you lie and anybody
including people who aren't like
religious know that if you lie you feel
bad and it can just feel like
soul-crushingly shivering like deep evil
bad when you lie yeah why would it feel
like that like why would it feel that
evil when you lie I mean for a normal
person it should feel like that and I
think it it does line up with
sin in in Christianity making you feel
that way
yeah I think because the way I kind of
look at it is like you have these
natural laws like say the law of gravity
you know or so you have these natural
laws like thermodynamics in these things
that government the physical universe
but it seems like there's a natural law
of love that governs us inside of the
universe you know our common moral
selves uh because when we get out of
alignment with that like we can't allow
ourselves because we have free will I
believe so we can't allow ourselves to
get more harder um harder and stuff
towards stuff and that's why CS Lewis
talked about like
um when you continue to do stuff you
need to become a better person or a
worse person from all your little
decisions because when you do something
bad it's easy to do something bad then
the next time and same with being good
you know but um I asked the the aspect
of like everybody having
um this kind of moral
um awareness of some sort even though
they're going to differ on stuff you
know depending on background information
but there's a moral awareness of some
sort that I think is interesting because
I think it makes more sense on theism
that God created us with the these with
these with this morality on our hearts
as the Bible says that makes more sense
to me than some sort of evolutionary
explanation
yeah it's hard to chalk up I've been one
of the disagreements I had although my
husband's I think is converting overs
like
um whenever I heard about Christians
especially like as a kid I was like oh
Christians the people who don't believe
in evolution like that's that's what I
knew about Christians the people who
don't believe in in evolution and and so
I've talked so I what's what's your
opinion on this okay
um and then I'll tell you my opinion you
go first what's your opinion on
Evolution okay okay so so here's my
opinion so it's it's and this is a
complex thing and I'm not too far into
it because I don't see it as really a
stumbling block for a lot of people
today
um a lot of the younger Generations they
don't really care if evolution is true
or not in order to believe in god so
let's try to spend a ton of time
focusing on it but my thinking of
something like this when I look at the
Bible you know you know 66 books you
know written The Wristband 1500 years
you know three different continents that
aspect but all of the different books
you have to understand what the genre is
right so when I look at like Psalms I
understand that's not a historical genre
you know what I mean when I look at the
gospels understand that it is
um ancient Roman bio you know what I
mean so I can understand if you're not
once and so you want to understand each
book of the Bible through its
appropriate lens
um so it's like the Proverbs you're not
like okay these are promises because the
problems on promises is wisdoms Proverbs
you know what I mean and so
um understanding that now in most places
in the Bible is pretty clear and pretty
straightforward but there's some places
in the Bible where we're not exactly
sure what it is for for different
reasons and so when it comes to the Book
of Genesis at least Genesis 1 and 12.
um it seems that there's something more
going on than it just being this like
historical narrative it seems to be
blending in
um just sort of like um the stories of
the culture at that time in the ancient
near East um blending again these
stories for a theological purpose that
that's the way I understand it at least
is because it seems like from a
theological purpose rather than just a
strict historical purpose that doesn't
seem to to make a lot of sense to me
logically when I'm looking at it and
then looking at the different accounts
and that sort of thing and then also
reading all of the the literature and
the ancient theories as well see that's
available
um but I think um so when it comes to
that and so I think about the guidelines
and then I look at the world you know
what I mean and try to see what makes
more sense
um I can't see
um the world making sense to me for it
to be six thousand years old that that
doesn't logically make sense to me and
it doesn't seem like it corresponds with
reality
um you can have ways around it but well
we can talk about those later if needed
but um but then I think you have bigger
problems so if you said God created it
and with the appearance of age then I
think you have bigger problems because
then how can you know anything at all
really you know what I mean because the
whole epistemic system is broken and so
that's a problem for me but um I I'd say
that what I found to be the most
persuasive and again I've only read a
few books on this but what I found to
take is the most persuasive evidence for
evolution would be like the pseudo genes
um so for example whales have like um
these organs their oscillatory receptors
and so it's their use for the tech and
violent chemicals outside of water but
these genes are dormant and so you
should have not created the will just as
is then why would he create it with
these genes you know I mean because
they're not being used so I think that's
probably some of the bigger evidence but
I still think that there's so many gaps
in the fossil records so
um yeah so it's really tough having
company like shown conclusions on it but
I think that there's something like
um some sort of or everybody believes in
evolution to some degree like there's
some sort of evolving process but I
don't tend to hold to the view I don't
think that you have these different
um uh these different uh kinds of
animals I hate using that time but these
different kinds of animals turning into
other kinds of animals so like the
distinction they make with like
macroevolution
um it doesn't seem that doesn't seem as
plausible to me but there is some sort
of thing going on where you have these
creatures that are like
um that have clearly shown some sort of
evolution
um from you know being land animals
water animals so on you know so there's
clearly some sort of evolution going on
I just don't think that it's that one
blanket term of like everything comes
from a single common
um you know similar common um can't
remember the time they use for it but
just like one one like an amoeba or
something like that yeah yeah
okay so what I've thought about and I've
had this discussion with my husband
because I don't think he'd really
thought about it before it's like who
cares but um right yeah like I have a I
took biomedical science a bunch of
courses biomedical science so I like got
taught Evolution so and I remember like
learning about Darwin and things so I
I've known this for a long time I I I
think that we've done quite a bit of
research going back towards like the big
bang that scientifically I I believe
what the scientific Community is saying
I think that lines up with the Bible
I just don't think the day period is
right so when it's like oh God created
the world in seven days I was like I
don't necessarily think that one of
those days for God is the same as one of
these 24-hour days for us
that's like the most logical
explanation to try and line up both of
those things because otherwise I can see
why people say that they don't line up
but I think yeah yeah one of the things
that like dissuaded me from Christianity
or made me look at Christians like they
didn't know what they were talking about
was like I put them in the same
categories like flat earthers I just as
a kid for whatever reason and I don't
know if that's because I was in like I
just wasn't around Christian people at
all but I just put them in my or I was
watching too much Simpsons like I'm not
sure what it was but yeah
because I mean uh and it's always tough
because it's like I respect people who
really take the Bible seriously you know
what I mean and we should take the Bible
seriously too but um sometimes it's like
they don't take it seriously enough
where they kind of do the interpretive
analysis with a lot of stuff because
like you can see that too with the day
the you know the day Theory too with
like yamas that word for day and then
you have these different um you have the
words of parents you know later on in
the Old Testaments who were part of
different periods of time then also you
know the scripture um wait say that
again
yeah say that again sorry
Oh no you're fine so um yeah so the word
for day in the Old Testament is Yom um I
believe my memory is looking great it's
been a while since I've looked at this
stuff
um but um I know you have later on in
the Old Testament too you have this word
use and it's not referring to just a
single linear day
um
yeah and so because of that yeah then so
it does allow for different
interpretations
um of that passage but I think it comes
down to that genre and because we're not
super aware of what that genre is I
think that we should be open-minded to
say how it should be interpret this but
the way I look at it is that everything
is theological out of its core so what
is the theological point that we get
from it and then how does that apply to
the rest of the Bible the story of the
Bible and also to our personal lives as
well
cool okay that's cool
um what what denomination do you
practice
a denomination
is that what he's called yeah yeah yeah
yeah
well it's funny because my wife is from
Tennessee and out there there's like all
this beef between like the Baptist and
the Church of Christ and stuff you know
because everybody identifies as
Christian out there but like out in
Colorado you're like I'm just happy to
see people who are Christians and taking
us seriously you know because we don't
we don't really do too many
denominations out here there's no
denomination beef that I'm aware of at
least but yeah oh that's funny okay
probably same kind of thing
well Toronto's pretty uh atheist or even
maybe agnostic but mostly atheist
um I think there's a lot of Catholicism
and Orthodoxy
and then yeah Christian like other
non-denominational I guess
that makes sense yeah I think yeah um
have you been looking at the
denominations at all or is it kind of
like not really gift that didn't think
so no not really
um whatever like Protestant is
I suppose yeah
yeah
okay yeah otherwise I mean I don't know
I honestly I probably don't know enough
about it to like come to a conclusive
decision but I feel like that there's
just like little differing rules
right yeah yeah it's like different
preferences basically so uh a lot of
them I mean so some people like the
um like different styles and different
kind of cultures and it's one of the
things that makes Christianity kind of
beautiful as well I think an aspect too
is like you have these different ways of
expressing
um your worship and and these sorts of
things too you know but the denomination
fact makes sense to me why we have so
much plurality and denominations and I
think it really the Bible kind of
explains we all have this tendency to
like want to elevate ourselves and
Elevate things that we think are
important and pride in this sort of
thing and so I think that that's the
other
um aspect of it there's a good side to
it and a bad side but the bad side is we
like to divide like we like to divide on
things that might not be as critical as
we like to think they are you know
because they're important to us we send
their importance into God you know in in
that aspect so we're like well this is
super important because I feel strongly
about this and you'll see that with all
the different kind of theological
accounts um but I think at least on the
Bible it makes sense you know because I
don't see how it makes sense on others
agent inspector we were talking about
earlier
no fair enough oh okay this is a good
one
um
do you have you seen more churches
becoming woke do you think this is
creeping into churches
yeah so I I guess the question is what
do you mean by awoke right so
um do you mean Luke is in woken like
some sort of
like um just a liberal uh sense or
uh I mean say well I mean for an extreme
example as I saw one church with a
transgender Jesus
I mean like I mean I mean that kind of
woke
I mean yeah
that's woke yeah I guess changing uh you
know not teaching
parts of the Bible because it doesn't
line up with
more Progressive attitudes have you seen
this happening or is this like right
wing propaganda that isn't real that's a
great question I I I don't think it's as
popular and I could be wrong on this
actually too because um I'd like to see
a statistical analysis of it but I don't
think it's as popular because when even
when I look at these type channels these
YouTube channels that are like these
super Progressive
um Progressive Christian channels uh
where they have like you know these
these type of transpassers or whatever
um they don't tend to have a lot of
followers either so I don't think it's
that attracted to a lot of people
um a lot of these channels so I see it
more as like um
um maybe like right wing taking
advantage of a situation you know what I
mean the show how bad the kind of
liberal agenda is and that sort of thing
uh but I could be wrong on that too I'm
open to being corrected
um but what I kind of see like this
makes me think what I kind of see is a
problem with
um uh with politics for Christians is
that when you look at the Bible you have
all of these different things things
that don't fit nice and neatly into one
category
um and I think it's Tim Taylor that's
talked about like
um for Christians that say there's like
um there's four things like the Bible
shows us that a person should be sold
out and against racial Injustice
um Christians should be deeply concerned
about the pull and the marginalized
Christians should be pro-choice or
pro-life I mean I'm sorry for life for
life and they should also um
um and they also hold to belief in a
um marriages only between a man and a
woman for a lifetime and so because of
that
um you have two of them sound
conservative two of them sound liberal
you know what I mean but the early
church was defined by all four you know
what I mean the early church was very
clear about all four of these things and
so because of that it kind of makes it
bad because if you go to the church and
say la
um you know a pastor is going to be
vocal about two of them you know and
then kind of hush about the other two
and then it's the same thing if you go
to church in Louisiana right you're
gonna have a uh the church is going to
be vocal about two and not vocal about
the other two but I think as Christians
we have to be um our world view needs to
be more integrated in terms of like
um a biblically grounded worldview
rather than it just being just solely
one political side I think we need to be
open to saying like what is what does
the Bible say about these issues rather
than what's either conservative
commentators say about these issues and
they're trying to make that fit into the
Bible and thinking that everything
liberals say is wrong you know what I
mean or vice versa I mean conservative
say is wrong so I think we need more of
a holistic approaches more biblically
grounded than it just being
um looking at one I mean one political
group and thinking that they represent
God another one doesn't per se you know
so
um so that's my view in politics where I
think that it's could be somewhat of an
issue for a lot of Christians because
there's a lot of pressure to conform all
of your views over to just one side of
the camp rather than having more nuanced
views that are in accordance with
scripture
um I agree
um do you do you think actually you'd
know the statistics better than me is um
is Christianity still shrinking or is it
making a comeback more recently or do I
just think it's making a comeback
because I converted yeah it's definitely
making a comeback
question um I think from last I've
looked it is still shrinking
um but what's interesting about it is
it's almost it's all it's like the same
question of what do you mean by
Christianity because a lot of people who
identify as nuns they say the nuns say
that they don't want to be identified as
a particular religion but um they're
still just as likely to hold belief in
God and belief in the Bible and their
prayer life and this sort of thing too
they just don't like the connotations or
whatever that Christianity is identified
with so this is what makes it kind of
hard because when we're asking a lot of
these questions on these surveys we're
not asking some of the right questions
we're asking some of the questions that
like
um people are gonna have to answer in a
binary way but it's more nuanced than
that and so I think that's where the
issue is because I think that probably
um I think there's probably still a high
degree of people
um that believe in something like
Christianity but I mean Biblical
literacy is so far low right now that
like it's hard to say like what do these
people mean to when they say they
identify as Christians you know like
have more of a view of culture or some
sort of relative view of Christianity
where everything is relative and I'll
take some parts of Christianity some
part of some parts of Buddhism or
whatever you know whatever works for my
life and so that's why I think a lot of
the statistics make it hard to kind of
tell what's really going on
that makes sense
um do you get
people like I suppose your audience is
mainly Christian do you get atheists
watching you just out of curiosity
yeah yeah
um and I'm not sure the percentage but
yeah I'll get some comments from
atheists I said they they like my
Channel or whatnot you know so
um but yeah no idea the percentage I'm
sure it's definitely a majority person
for sure you know at least probably 90
at least I'd assumed but yeah
what made you want to debate people
about this sounds like my worst
nightmare
yeah no that's a great question too uh
for me like um I like to hear different
sides that everything that I'm
considering so that way I can think it
through well on my own
um because I think like if I'm missing
um the other sides of the argument then
how am I supposed to weigh that and then
how am I supposed to communicate to
people trying to convince them of the
other side and so it's really important
to me because that's what I did a lot of
my fleshing out for like a lot of the
early stuff that I came to believe a lot
of the fleshing out was me actually just
debating it and then trying to take into
consideration what the other side was
saying as charitably as possible you
know so that way I can understand what I
even believe so for me it was like a lot
of processing
um like today I mean I'm not that
interested in debating people as much
you know but I mean I don't really mind
the baits like it doesn't They Don't
Really worry me but I'm not really that
interested because I think that the
purpose they service it's it's kind of
limited in a lot of ways because people
are just more polarized on stuff you
know so like conversations are a lot
better than just like you know trying to
prove yourself side you know because
then people just shut down and won't
take in any new information for the most
part
who are your favorite uh I don't know
what the right word for this is I'd say
like thought leaders in the kind of yeah
online for Christians who do you follow
yeah so
um
so I'd say like if we're gonna say like
my kind of main kind of influences
that's had the biggest impact on how I
think there we go outside of it yeah
outside of um like Paula Apostle is
where like a lot of like my arguments
and stuff are really formulated from
Paul which is which is interesting but
outside of like the Bible um I'd say um
William and Craig played a really big
role in shaking how I think
um because this is where I kind of
learned how to think more deductively
and think more philosophically and
concise and make these distinctions and
Define words
um you know so that way you can
understand what you're saying is
foundation and then stack up so um he
was a really big influence
um Tim Keller was a really big influence
um because of his gospel Centric Focus
which is uh similar to what um I've took
influence for with my channel I was
having more of a gospel
um Center focus to show people the
relevancy of the Gospel in their lives
um and for non-believers too to see how
the gospel can make sense and integrate
into their lives
um and then um my best friend is other
one you know his name is Joey fukamoto
but me and him um we've we've debated
about everything like everything so it's
like he's helping me think better
because what we do is before we even
like bring up some sort of like argument
or something we always know that we have
to like the final terms you know it's
like what do you mean by that and how
did you come to that conclusion those
are two questions in the book tactics
um but like we're constantly doing this
with each other and we like to argue
about everything and it's really good
and healthy because he'll push me on
stuff I'll push him on stuff and we both
just keep getting sharper because of it
you know so we have to think things
through better because he doesn't let me
get away with anything and I don't let
him get away with any kind of lazy
thinking either so I think that um and
he's brilliant by the way he's way
smarter than me and so because of that I
think it's really kind of helped as well
kind of like you know test out stuff
with him and then try to argue with him
about stuff and then figure stuff out
together so so those are probably my top
three influences that's uh
that's cool okay that's fun
um so you you brought up before so you
said you you had health problems too you
had this you have this hearing thing
which is Major yeah
um how did that and and that's when you
started kind of debating people online
um you said you were first exposed to
Christianity when you were 15 but in
kind of a
culty way yeah for lack of better words
um what made you switch into taking it
more seriously was it before you got
sick
um
no
um that's what's kind of interesting
about it so
um really it was like kind of during
that
um during the last time when I was doing
these debates that's when I started kind
of thinking way more about it than ever
thought before too like I thought a lot
about it in college taking philosophy
religion course and stuff and after it
but kind of like it kind of
reinvigorated that in me um during that
time and then when it comes to like um
The Gospel that's a that's a longer
story but that's one thing that really
kind of changed for my life I think is
everything changed once I continued to
start learning the gospel more really
working out understanding these
different perspectives and stuff and
then internalizing that gospel message
is when everything really changed
um so I guess I can kind of run through
it briefly but
um
so I guess when I first converted to
Christianity I wasn't really like that
clear on the relationship between works
and salvation
um because I think everybody has like
these kind of muddled views or but I
think a Protestant problem I'd say more
so is they have more of a modeled view
of like where do Works fit in with
salvation this sort of thing
um and so I had to view this somewhere
kind of like I'd say most people
probably have this where it's like well
if you're a Christian you know you're
going to be producing tons of good works
and then by looking up these good works
you can tell somebody's a Christian or
not
um but um I remember there was a guy
that came in to a reasonable Faith
meeting that I was teaching here locally
um teaching on like apologetics and
stuff and um he was asking these tough
questions he says like you can a
Christian live like Hitler and still be
saved you know what I mean which is
questions that's super uncomfortable for
people you know what I mean it's like
um super uncomfortable because you want
to say yeah but then you're like no that
sounds so bad you know what I mean so
you don't really then you were like no
that's too counterintuitive you know
um but really like during this time I
spent a few I think I spent about two
and a half years at least I think me and
um my friend too my best friends um and
also talking with a lot of other people
really working through all of these
scriptures and stuff what are these
scriptures that seem to say works and
what do they say about salvation and so
we went through all these scriptures we
saw the talking and thinking through
this stuff and
um you know looking at all these
different views and commentaries and I
became convinced that I think works were
saved completely by Grace Grace is a
free gift we're safe completely
vibrational Faith yeah completely by
verse through faith I don't think I
think that the Bible's pretty clear
about this and
um I mean so many passages Romans 11 6
makes a distinction what Paul says
basically if it's Bob race it can't be
through faith uh because I'm sorry if
it's libraries that can't be through
works because most of our works it would
no longer be Grace like clear
distinction I give you a gift you know
um then it's like you have Christian
Living
um how you want it how you're supposed
to live how you're supposed to love
others treat God treat others and stuff
after
um that salvation that's how you're
supposed to live your life now to be in
court in accordance with you know what I
mean this this new lifestyle is giving
you
um but I think that like a lot of times
Christians we all have a tendency to
like want to like look down and say
these other people are saved because
we're we don't like the way they're
living you know what I mean people can
look at my tattoos and say I'm not safe
you know what I mean and so whatever's
important to people we tend to be really
judgmental towards those things because
I think that's part of our sin nature
you know and to be completely Fair it's
completely count intuitive to think that
Christians can do bad stuff um like
really bad stuff to really encounter
intuitive but reality on the Bible shows
us that that's the case you know and
um so really there's like a lot of
passages like James two where fake of
our works is dead and Matthew 7 passage
where Jesus says the part for me I never
knew you there's all these different
kind of scriptures people kind of run to
um to say that a Christian
um by necessity has to be producing good
works but
um I don't think that that's necessarily
the case because I think everybody
produces good works and then it's a
slippery slope because uh Bill and
Melinda Gates for example they say
millions of African kids lives you know
what I mean so it's like is that not
good works sure that's that's more good
Works than I might do in this life you
know what I mean and so you have this
kind of subjective elements of like what
constitutes is good works like how many
works is enough to prove that you're
saved you know what what kinds of Works
who determines what kinds of works and
those sort of things so for the
Protestant circles I think we have a lot
of that kind of messiness there like at
least the Catholics are clear about it
you know what I mean where they say you
have the renal sense and the Mortal sins
that's clear but
um my view personally what I think is
the most consistent in particular
scripture is that I think Christians I
believe we have free will which is
another thing that like some Calvinists
might not agree with and um at least
libertarian if you will so I think in
that aspect I think that like Christians
can live bad lives because we're saved
by grace through faith alone and so it's
like we can be saved and be bad
Christians so you can be a bad disciple
because Jesus says you're going to be a
disciple that's going to cost you
something you're going to have to deny
yourself follow me you know what I mean
and all these things like um uh pick up
your cross and it's hyperbolic but he
says hey your mother and father and wife
and kids um in comparison to him that's
costly for a Salvation he paid the cost
for it's by his grace and and so I
really kind of need internalizing that
deeper and deeper and thinking man it's
really a free gift the more I actually
really internalized that and thought
about it that's when everything in my
life seemed to change and I don't know
if it's
um like psychologically you you guys you
and your dad probably know better but
it's like when you know that you have
this unconditional love and acceptance
and then you have somebody that's also
pushing you then you can change you know
what I mean you can change from the
inside then but you can't change if
you're trying to meet these quotas I'm
outside and focus on how good you are
and that sort of thing to me that never
worked for me and I don't think it's
like consistent with with um some
scripture here but yeah I mean do you
kind of know like I think an AAA or
something like that I think they have
some sort of acceptance kind of theory
too which really helps people change I
think I don't know how it works I don't
know I don't know enough about AAA I
know that it's helped a lot of people
I've had some other people on my podcast
and it's completely transformed their
lives too
um going back to what you were saying
about works
so I I think we're in agreement from
like the limited time I've spent reading
and studying these things and talking to
other people about it I I'm in agreement
it's a weird it's a weird thing to say
that you could be saved regardless of
works yeah you know yeah um but I think
yeah it is counter-intuitive but I think
it also it's like relaxing it gives you
a level of ease that maybe allows you to
be good right yeah because you're not
doing it you know it's not good and
resentful people experience this it's
not good to do things for somebody else
because you think you have to that's not
good even if you end up doing doing like
good things if you're doing them
to stop someone from being angry or
because you feel guilty or because you
think you have to uh you're just gonna
end up resentful it's not going to be
good for anyone you're going to end up
overdoing it for people you're not going
to have the proper boundaries I used to
be like that and I used to feel I think
because I was sick too I felt guilty all
the time so I was always trying to help
more than I should help and I think like
you know being saved without
it being tied to Works allows you to
kind of relax and then have the proper
boundaries to allow you to do what you
should be doing rather than doing it out
of out of guilt so there might be
it's probably something to that so I
agree anyway yeah yeah and what's
interesting is there's a passage in
where Paul in Galatians 5 16 where Paul
says he can step at the spirit and then
you won't gratify the desires of the
Flesh and what's so interesting about
that is because he's talking about all
these things with the Flesh and he's not
saying don't do these things and then
you know you're going to be okay like
resist them you know what I mean and
that sort of way in this passage but
he's saying uh basically it's like when
you keep your mind kind of focused on
for like the gospel you know what I mean
like keep your mind and keep in step of
the spirit then you're not going to
gratify the desires of the Flesh and
that's what I kind of noticed too
because that shame and guilt and all
that stuff once that stuff kind of just
went away that's when I actually had the
desire I mean the willpower the ability
to be able to stop doing these things
that were like controlling me for so
long you know and so it's super
counterintuitive just like between
enemies comments who would have you know
I think a lot of the fundamental
proficient stuff is counter-intuitive
which is why people naturally push back
people that's why the gospel message is
offensive as Paul talks about
Revelations five and six because it's
super offensive because that that's
offensive to think that like somebody
lives an awful life like Jeffrey Dahmer
could be in heaven because he believed
in in Christianity you know which I've
done a video on but I think God's grace
is big enough to save any of us yeah you
know yeah it's pretty weird but
I don't know life is pretty weird and I
mean we're told that we can't even you
know I believe like can't even
understand what God is like right can't
he can't see it you know people are
blinded can't understand it so then who
are we to understand the reasoning here
yeah and that was one of the things that
helped me believe Christianity was true
because I thought about I said if you
were going to make up a religion why
would you make up the Trinity for out of
all things right you know what I mean
like he was kind of talk about the most
counterintuitive thing that you can say
to people you're like you know you're
like why why the Trinity you know
um but I think the gospel message is
similar because every other religion on
the planet believes in a Salvation based
on works every single other religion on
the planet and so when I didn't know
Christians thought oh yeah they all
believe you have to do something and you
have to keep doing these things in order
to be saved and Christianity says no
it's a free gift Jesus did everything so
that way you could be saved so that's a
radically different claim which is super
offensive you know and so I understand
the offense but yeah but it's you know I
think it's the only thing in some ways
that really makes sense it's the only
thing that makes sense in my in my mind
because
um if we could if we have to do all
these things then it's like man who can
say like when Jesus gets to the heart
like in Matthew 5 or there's a sermon of
their mouth he's like if you looked at a
woman with lust you've committed
adultery in your art right and you're
like dang well if you even looked at a
woman you're violating the laws so like
all of these rules people try to come up
with to say
um you know I know I'm safe because I
don't do these things and I'm like well
your heart would probably do and you're
condemning yourself you know so yeah
that's why I think it's just such a
beautiful and humbling and count
intuitive message like it's so bizarre
all at the same time you know
I love it okay John if people aren't
familiar with you where can they go to
find you online
yeah just go to what do you mean
um it's spelled we're at
w-h-e-s-w-h-a-d-d-o and then
y-o-u-m-e-m-e uh what do you mean by all
the social media platforms and and
you'll find me
okay thank you very much for coming on
that was fine that's so interesting it's
so strange it's so interesting we'll
have to do it again sometime yeah
definitely saying sounds good all right
thanks for having me all right bye-bye
[Music]